you're going to be absolutely horrified
when you hear how evil Twitter is before
musk took over Twitter let the US
government use their platform for
literal propaganda see the US government
needs the people of Yemen Syria Iraq and
Kuwait to support America you know
because of the drone strikes oil Wars
destabilizations of governments Etc so
the Pentagon created a bunch of fake
Arabic news accounts on Twitter so they
could quote amplify certain messages
unquote like at Yemen current which
tweeted announcements about U.S drone
strikes and how the drone strikes were
accurate and how they definitely did not
kill civilians the Pentagon sent these
propaganda accounts to Twitter and
Twitter willingly white listed them and
some of these accounts are still active
click the link below to learn the evil
secret to how the US really got so
powerful because